every technology I look at is now
entering this exponential curve Ray
Kurzweil says that as any technology
becomes information
it starts advancing exponentially it
seems that everything is being digitized
now and every technology I look at seems
to be entering this exponential curve
and what happens is that when technology
is advancing on exponential curves
they're doing amazing things but when
technologies converge when exponential
technologies converge that's when you
get industry disruptions behind
everything is computing you know this
device over here but my estimate is more
powerful than 40 Cray supercomputers
were remember Cray supercomputers that
that were just a cost in the tens of
millions of dollars that had expert
controls on them this is more powerful
than those crazy supercomputers well
there's something in computing called
Moore's Law what Moore's law stipulates
is that the processing power of
computers doubles every year or two it's
actually the number of transistors but
what effect happens is that the power
increases the cost drops and this and
the size becomes smaller this
exponential curve that computing is on
means that faster computers can design
faster computers with faster computers
you can now design new types of sensors
with faster computers you can now build
artificial intelligence with faster
computers you can now analyze data like
wooden egg you can never analyze before
when you have artificial intelligence
and sensors and robots coming together
you get r2d2 from from Star Wars you get
these humanoid robots that can do what
human beings can do you get the ability
now to have robots that can stock your
shelves that can operate machinery that
can be receptionists in your offices so
you have multiple technologies coming
together which which make it possible to
do things that could never be done
before if you look at drones what our
drones we've had flying machines for a
long time but these flying machines we
used to build these toys we build
destroy helicopters weren't stable when
you added Adreno chips to them when you
added computing to them and you added a
little bit of artifice to artificial
intelligence to them so they could keep
track of all the data around them you
had the ability to have these drones
being stable and now ship goods so
drones are advancing almost
exponentially and those drones are going
to disrupt the entire logistics industry
imagine now being able to to have your
mail being delivered to your mailbox
using drone imagine having packages
being delivered by drone imagine having
us being delivered by drone I'm not
kidding look at each eye and what
they're doing in Dubai that's really our
drone on steroids that's being used to
transport human beings so every industry
I look at I see as being ready for major
disruption manufacturing is going to
come back to United States in fact it is
coming back to United States right now
because of robots they can do what human
beings can do you have finance that's
about to be disrupted because you have
Robo advisors you have digital
currencies you now have data which
canalize stock trades and so on all of
these advances happening we talk about
to disrupt finance when you look at
transportation you have electric cars
which are becoming cheaper and cheaper
because of the advances in battery
technologies you have self-driving
technologies because of the advances in
a I imagine self-driving electric cars
that cost about fifteen or twenty
thousand dollars in the year 2025 what
do you think is gonna happen to GM Ford
Toyota all of these companies will still
need one or two electric companies but
more likely than not there will be some
upstarts from Silicon Valley or from New
Delhi or from South Paulo that put the
right technologies together and that are
inexpensive that start disrupting the
entire transportation industry soon
we're gonna have virtual reality that's
going to disrupt education itself
imagine mio to put glasses on and watch
me watch this in three dimensions and in
converse with me imagine being able to
meet with people interactively on the
moon on or on Mars or in Tahiti that's
going to disrupt the entire conferencing
industry because we'll be able to have
meetings in exotic places and it will
feel like we're almost there
right education imagine being able to
learn science by by doing virtual
experiments Anatomy by seeing your human
body inside and out imagine learning
mathematics by going into ancient Egypt
and building pyramids imagine learning
Latin by going back in time
and talking to people in Latin I mean
this is all becoming possible and this
is within five years we'll have them
imagine having digital tutors that that
monitor your expressions cameras can
already do that and then monitor that
with the child's interest in learning if
the child likes to play games he plays
games with them the child likes to play
to watch videos it takes them into
three-dimensional holographic worlds and
lets them experience you have
experiences and learn on their own if
the child likes reading books
it reads books to them so we're talking
about disrupting education itself now
granted that the in the Harvard's the
Carnegie Mellon's you know the elite
universities were sort of a brand name
we still value them but the world's
masses will be able to now get into
holographic worlds and learn in many new
ways every single industry where
technology can be applied is about to be
disrupted in in in a big way let's look
at our own health what's happening now
is that we become data in our doctors of
gaming software let me explain
we wear Fitbit so we were all these you
know devices that monitor our body's
functioning move forward five years and
we'll have sensors in our clothing
imagine that fruit of the Loom tag in
your underwear which is monitoring you
24/7 monitoring your activity levels
which is monitoring your EKG is you know
all these these different symptoms that
can be captured from the skin
imagine it being gathered 24/7 being
uploaded to the cloud and having an AI
now analyzing the data and say look
you're about to get sick you need to get
some exercise and then having all of
these cameras and sensors which watch
what we eating and what we're doing and
saying all right Vivek you don't need
that extra piece of pie stop abort abort
abort this is all becoming possible and
in the next five years or so we should
be able to build these technologies so
we have digital doctors now the second
part of it genomics in the year 2000
there was a race between the US
government and a scientist craig Venter
to sequence a human genome the
government and affiliated labs spent two
point seven five billion dollars Venter
came up with a hundred million dollars
don't ask how but he took government
data
any sequence a human genome it made
front-page news worldwide for a long
time nothing happened we thought
genomics was a waste of money but over
the last two or three years it's now
gone at this exponential curve there
studies being published very frequently
now almost every week you're seeing
groundbreaking studies about the
discoveries you know discoveries in
genomics the correlations between our
health and our genes but you know
something what blows my mind the most is
the microbiome when you went to school
your teacher your biology teacher taught
you that we made up of cells and the
cells of a nucleus and that's where your
DNA is do you know something what she
taught you was wrong
we made up a bacteria we have somewhere
between two and ten times more bacteria
in our body than we have cells the same
technology which was sequence there used
to sequence the human body and that's
being used to sequence plants has been
sequenced he's been used to sequence a
bacteria and our gut and for the last
few years they have been major
breakthrough than this now I have a
Google Alert on the word microbiome
every day I read new studies new
breakthroughs happening with the
microbiome it seems that the DNA is
important and relevant but we may be
looking under the wrong lamp over here
there are all sorts of studies which is
showing that it's what we eat and the
this these trillions of bacteria that we
have in our in our body the you know the
amount that they may be regulating our
health you know for example they were
study there was a study published in
Nature magazine about a year and a half
ago in which they took the the feces if
I can say this on Big Think feces means
shit a fat Mouse and gave it to a thin
Mouse and the thin Mouse gained weight
they took the feces from a thin Mouse
and gave it to a fat Mouse and the fat
Mouse lost weight now the Chinese also
replicated some of these findings in
human beings and they determined that
there's a correlation between obesity
and your microbiome so forget all these
diets we've been obsessed with could it
simply be a matter of taking the feces
of a thin person and giving it to a fat
person and the fat person loses weight
let's watch the space over the next five
years we'll have scientific evidence of
this and also curing disease they've
been studies to show that Crohn's
disease which which is a debilitating
disease that children get they took the
feces of a healthy child and gave it to
an unhealthy child and it appears that
this unhealthy child was cured your
curing disease by transplanting bacteria
it doesn't make sense and then
antibiotics
they've been several studies which show
that children who received antibiotics
tend to be obese it may well be that
antibiotics are killing off entire
species the bacteria in our body and
they're making us sick you know this is
a crazy prediction and but I really
believe this is going to happen that
within 10 or 15 years we will come to
the conclusion that antibiotics were
destroying our health it may well be
that we look at antibiotics the same way
we look at those leeches that they use
to suck out blood from patients in in in
in England and you know the belief was
that you could cure health by sucking
out blood using leeches okay that may be
what antibiotics are doing to us still
emerging technology we don't know yet
but when I read these studies every day
that is a conclusion I'm getting to that
the entire Western medical system is
about to be up ended through the
microbiome so move forward to the 2020s
we have all of these diagnostic data we
have all of these data about our genome
and our microbiome we have data are not
thousands of people but hundreds and
millions of people and we have AI that
analyzes all of these information that
app on your smartphone that's monitoring
you 24/7 maybe the best doctor you've
ever had it's your friend it's your
adviser it guides you on how to maintain
optimal health and it guides you on how
to get healed if you do get sick this is
510 maximum 15 years from now I think
closer to in the five to ten you know
your period they will have all these
amazing advances so this is exponential
it's incredible it's amazing and what
the future holds in health
[Music]
if you look at artificial intelligence I
know when I was young I was reading
about how AI would soon be able to
defeat humans at playing chess and
everything else so all these predictions
made in the 1960s about how a I would
become smarter than man and then in the
1980s in the 1990s we heard about Japan
and their fifth generation project we
sort of thought that Japan would rule
the world in in AI and then what
happened nothing happened we basically
had what was called the nuclei winter
that there was a cloud cast over AI we
thought it was a hoax it was a
fraudulent and AI was dead AI isn't dead
ai is everywhere because here's here's
what happened the scientists also
started speculating on a new method of
doing AI the AI that defeated Garry
Kasparov big blue was really a decision
tree it did if-then-else statements a
very possible chess move and with super
fast computers it was able to outsmart a
human being that's really you know
simplifying the technology but that's
more or less the AI we had a decade of
15 years ago
and scientists started speculated that
maybe we could do a different form of AI
we could mimic the human brain the human
brain has layers of neurons which you
know and the connections between the
neurons are programmed based on what's
learnt so a child sees a dog and mom
says this is a doggy
this is a cat and this and the neurons
are just some cells to to associate that
that image of you know an animal with
ears and a tail and so on the shape with
the dog
so our brain programmed their self based
on what it learns so scientists
speculated they were papers published 30
years about this that we could do AI
using neural networks here's what the
problem was to do neural networks you
needed massively parallel computers we
didn't have those even the fastest
supercomputers of their time in the
1970s and 1980s and even 1990s couldn't
do massively parallel computing about
you know decade ago NVIDIA and
I decided to develop a chip to let
children play video games better the GPU
in the graphic processing unit and they
released it a few years ago it became a
big success and then scientists started
looking at that GPU and realized that
that's a massively parallel computer why
can't we now do AI with it
so I started doing it and machine
learning developed there are many words
over here but essentially we started
mimicking the human brain and using
these these you know these GPUs to learn
the way human beings do that's when you
started having Elon Musk and Stephen
Hawking and a bunch of others talking
about artificial general intelligence
saying oh my god these things they're
gonna be smarter than us and all of
these dangers the trouble was that that
was the stuff of science fiction and
this was narrow AI where you
specifically taught a computer what to
learn you developed a model and then you
threw data at it and it learned from
that so we assumed that you know this
AGI was 20-30 years away here's what
happened in the last couple of weeks
with narrow you know narrow AI that a a
bunch of scientists figured out how to
defeat CAPTCHA by having the computer
learn itself it did experiments it
really tried every combination figured
it out and then Google was able to to
have alpha comb which is you know defeat
these go players it learned on its own
so it seems like narrow AI is running on
its own now you can throw anything you
want at it you take that one step
further and you say okay I can learn
anything it wants to learn and you begin
to see artificial general artificial
general intelligence the stuff out of
science fiction becoming possible so
this is all happening a lot faster than
anyone anyone imagined I mean maybe
there's some people who saw it coming
but the vast majority of experts in this
field didn't think that AI would
progress at the rate it's progressed
just over the last few weeks and it
could well be that we get our two day to
remember Star Wars Rosie from the
Jetsons Samantha from her all of these
things we saw in science fiction that
they start showing up in our apps and in
these BOTS we have at home in the next
seven to ten years
so me I won't be surprised if I'm able
to order Rosie on amazon.com in the year
2025 2027 and she's droned over to my
house and Rosie cost about $10,000
because that is how AI and robotics and
whole bunch of other technologies are
advancing exponentially ever since the
internet came out we've started ordering
things on the internet with the first
one that some of the earliest websites
were these these websites these
retailing websites where you could buy
oddities on the on the internet and then
we could buy clothing on the Internet
and then you could buy shoes on the
Internet and now Amazon has become a
dominant player because practically
everything you need can be ordered on
the internet and it comes to your house
often within an hour or so so that was
retail disruption 101 now something even
more dramatic is happening that the
retail store itself is becoming
digitized when you walk into your
supermarket when you walk into any
retail store you know that their cameras
over there you know over the last two
years or so the ability for for
computers to recognize faces exceeded
the ability of human beings to recognize
faces so those cameras now have the
ability to know who you are
and they have the ability now to just do
interface with the registers where you
buy things and to keep track over here
but you're bought give it five or ten
years and you'll be walking up to the
counters and you'll have you know you'll
have ads being served to you based on
your buying habits and based on your
interests so the entire retail
experience begins to change because you
have customized coupons customized ads
all being selves to you as you walk in
there but then also the sensors I talked
about the cameras they can also detect
inventory they can see what's on the
shelves how much of it has been solved
you know until today we've had human
beings going and doing inventory checks
every two or three days they go and see
what needs to be stacked and so on but
with these cameras they can keep track
of what's on the shelves and they can
automatically order a new
you know replenishments as needed and
then when have robots they can go and
replenish the cell shelves rather than
human beings going in and stacking you
know our sale boxes imagine you had
robots that can do that already the
number of robotic technologies that can
they can go in and and do this thing but
give it five or seven years we'll have
robots replenishing shelves we'll have
sensors and AI monitoring inventory move
forward a couple of years virtual ready
is going to become much more powerful
imagine wearing eyeglasses that turn
dark and take you into holographic
worlds imagine now being able to to meet
people wherever you want to and being
able to converse with them as if you
were there imagine now being able to go
into a store and now pick and choose
what you want from it being able to
examine the merchandise and just say
okay I'll take it and imagine having it
drawn over to your house let me switch
gears now and talk about saving the
world because I live in Silicon Valley
and frankly I get depressed at the fact
that they're tens of billions of dollars
being thrown at mindless apps they what
happens is if some kid comes up with
some new stupid app and he gets you know
100 meant all the funding and other VCS
give throw another hundred million
dollars competitors I did you know we're
basically chasing rainbows in Silicon
Valley and not understanding the
problems of the world I was born in
India I traveled the world and when I go
there I see poverty I see despair I see
you know people living in ill health I
see hunger I see disease I see you know
majority I see people getting sick
because of bad water and it's depressing
to see that we living in Silicon Valley
we're blessed living in New York City
you're blessed because you have
everything you need we don't we know we
see poverty and we ignore it but by and
large we're not sensitive to the needs
of the world you travel to the
developing world you see the the dire
poverty and the pain and suffering but
you know something I believed in the
next 10 or 15 years we can solve
virtually all of these problems that are
there are
you know hurting people so much the the
biggest problem is energy when people in
remote parts of India Africa South
America come home they can't study
because they don't have light this is
something we can't comprehend in America
that you don't have light you can't
study there for children don't get
education but this is a common problem
in the developing world 88% of the
infectious disease in the developing
world is caused by water borne viruses
you know when you went to school you
learnt how to distill water what do you
do you boil it you capture the
condensation and that's the distilled
water distilled water is 100 percent
pure there's nothing living in it right
now all it takes to have 100 percent
clean water to boil the oceans and have
all the water we need is energy the
trouble is that energy has been so
expensive well guess what that's
changing we're headed into an era of
unlimited clean and almost free energy
here's what's happening solar wind takes
solar as an example the cost of solar
has dropped 99% since 1976 and what
happens is it as the price drops the
installation of installations doubled as
the installations doubled the price
drops were in a virtuous cycle over here
of of exponential technology advances at
the pace we're going we're only about
six doublings away from having the
capability of generating 100 percent of
the Earth's energy needs through solar
this sounds crazy and the doublings are
happening less than every two years from
now so what I'm saying is that by 2030
or so we could have unlimited clean
energy on this planet from sunlight and
the cost will be a fraction of what it
is today imagine 1/16 of what it is
today one thirtieth of what it is today
you know in less than 15 years from now
this seems crazy this seems unimaginable
but all you have to do is look at the
data look at the trend it is as clear as
can be now in America we're regressing
because you now have the US government
and when I say US government I mean
Donald Trump talking about bringing coal
back he's talking about stopping the
progress of solar energy because it
disrupts the USA unemployment this is
complete nonsense
I mean solar is generating more jobs
than coal ever had and this is good for
America it's good for the world but
regardless leave America aside America
is not relevant anymore the really good
news over here is that America isn't
leading the world anymore it's China
number one they have committed to I
think 200 gigawatts in the next five or
seven years in India number two they
talk about 100 gigawatts we're talking
about you know the two largest
population countries in the world now
leading the path on solar and even if
America decides to bring cold back and
set up coal-fired plants it doesn't
matter the world world will simply laugh
at us the cost of solar will still
advance and the beauty of this is that
every village in the world will now have
light now the the challenge over here is
that you need to store the energy
because it doesn't the Sun doesn't shine
when it's not sunny the wind doesn't
blow and it's not windy but the good
thing is that the cost of storage is
also dropping exponentially we should
talk about three four five hundred or
the kilowatt hour for storage Elon Musk
is hinting at $100 a kilowatt hour in
the next three or four years and it
could go to $70 a kilowatt hour when you
talk about prices such as that you're
talking about self-driving electric cars
called a costing about fifteen twenty
thousand dollars being able to drive 200
miles by the mid-2020s 2025 we could
have cars that cost fifteen thousand
dollars and go you know 100 200 miles
we're talking about now having enough
storage for a village for a couple of
thousand dollars so which means that you
could have entire village as the entire
towns all over the world which are off
the grid and have unlimited clean energy
so now we can have unlimited clean water
because we could just boil the oceans we
can now have lights the children can
come home and study and we can educate
them because they'll also have smart
phones that provide them with knowledge
we can now have diagnostic devices which
provide them with information so that
they can get in their smartphone and get
health they can grow have vertical farms
this is another amazing technology that
we don't talk very much about in the
United States but vertical farming is
now advancing exponentially because of
two or three different convergence
first of all LED lighting we don't have
to understand that LED lighting now has
become cost about the same as as these
old bulbs we had the Edison bulbs in the
developing was there even cheaper and
LED lighting there was a nobel prize two
years ago for LED lighting they've been
such amazing breakthroughs in LED
lighting so that you can now turn the
frequencies to the growth of plants so
you can now have inexpensive energy LED
lights and now you can also have sensor
sentiment sensors cameras and other
devices which may monitor crop growth
which monitor the growth of every plant
give them exactly the right nutrients
glasshouses
so we're talking about organic food we
will be able to grow almost unlimited
food because of these advances in energy
LED lighting ai and sensors that's in
the next five or ten years so we could
literally have a planet that's abundant
in energy in food that has perfect
health in which we can 3d print our own
clothing all of these things are within
reach now they make it to the dark side
of all this you know I talked about the
advances in AI and robotics in sensors
industry disruptions despite what the
optimists say despite what Silicon
Valley says I don't see a scenario in
which we will have enough jobs for human
beings that yes it'll be new jobs
created zumba dancers and God knows what
else what is these stupid examples that
Tech boggles throw up about the new jobs
that we created the fact is that these
uber drivers these taxi drivers in New
York City the even the uber drivers that
we have here now when they Jobs get
displaced they aren't going to be new
jobs for them
the truck drivers talking about 3
million truck drivers this in the United
States when we have self-driving trucks
which is very likely in the next five
years or so those middle-aged truck
drivers who don't have other skills than
driving are not going to be able to
learn how to program robots or how to do
is Zumba dancing those truck drivers
will be on
employed we're talking about people
whose livelihood depends on jobs whose
social stature depends on jobs I mean
you know think about it when we meet
each other the almost the first question
we ask is what do you do we defined by
our jobs and we take pride and
creativity in our work and our lives
revolve around our work what happens
when the work disappears even if you
have all the energy you want all the
food you want you have perfect health
you have all the things you need you
able to 3d print you your food and
clothing and all that if you have all of
these things taken care of you have
nothing to do you feel depressed what's
the new social structure over here what
do we do with ourselves so Silicon
Valley talks about universal basic
income that's the excuse for saying it's
someone else's problem
it'll be okay let us get filthy rich and
let someone else worry about the problem
we can just give money to everyone no
people just don't want money people want
a purpose in life they want to be
contributing to society they want to be
doing good they want to be be earning
their keep they don't want free money
next you know 10 15 years I worry about
Amy even as soon as five years I worry
about millions of people ten tens of
millions of people becoming unemployed
becoming depressed and really rebelling
that you know go back to the Luddite
movements who tried to stop the progress
of Technology because their livelihoods
were being taken away I worry about this
dark scenario I worry about them wanted
to burn down the tech companies and to
stop progress at all costs because their
jobs are being taken away strikes just
like you had strikes in Paris texts in
your taxi drivers trying to burn down
lubbers I'm exaggerating a little bit
but it's going to stop Uber's you may
have that in New York City you may have
people whose lives have been you know
displaced you met people who have lost
their livelihood is now getting angrier
and protesting look at what's happening
do you see we have a government that's
pandering to the extremist groups to the
anger right I mean it was unimaginable
even two years ago that we would be
accusing the White House of being Nazi
sympathizers I mean this is crazy
I mean the allegations are not founded
but the fact that we can even make those
allegations shows that something is
wrong over here that the the the gap
between the haves and the have-nots has
grown not only in money which is
obviously talked about before but also
in knowledge in culture in values we
take not be this a technology literate
that you get your information online you
watch videos such as this and you stay
up to date with this the people in
Middle America the truck drivers the
taxi drivers many of them don't watch
this and they're not up to date we're
doing nothing to mitigate the the gap
there are policy makers are talking
about taking things away taking
healthcare away from people taking
benefits away from people they're not
talking about how do we now uplift all
the mankind they think we have limited
resources and they're favored we have to
ration them but they don't simply
realize that we herded ed into an era of
abundance in which we can now distribute
the prosperity we're creating and uplift
all of mankind
[Music]
in my book the driver in the driverless
car I try to look at technology through
three lenses and the purpose of this was
to figure out how we can create the
amazing future of Star Trek versus the
darkness of Mad Max the three lenses are
number one there's a technology of the
potential to benefit everyone equally
can we make sure that everyone gets good
healthcare from it can we make sure that
everyone gets clean energy from it can
we make sure that everyone benefits from
the technology so that we don't have
people being left out and we don't have
anger brewing you know go back to movies
such as War of the Worlds go back to a
lot of these science fiction horror
movies in these movies the rich had
access to better technology that they
had health they had you know all sorts
of good things the poor had nothing they
were working in the mines the outcome
was always the same in all of these
movies that the poor ended up killing
the rich Mad Max that the anger started
brewing and rebellion started and the
focus was to destroy technology to you
know to
to kill the rich basically this is what
happens in all of these dark movies if
we don't now start educating and
uplifting everyone we're gonna have Mad
Max the second lens is do the rewards
outweigh the risks is this technology
going to benefit us or is it going to
hurt us we have to look at every
technology to make sure that the rewards
outweigh the risks you know for example
gene editing CRISPR we now have the
ability to alter life itself in about a
decade from now we will have the ability
to select the the the features that our
children have this sounds crazy but we
may be able to take pills that alter the
genome of an embryo and give them new
characteristics remember to remove
disease and to give them maybe extra IQ
this is all becoming possible now the
question if you do that do not create
the the world of Gattaca that movie
Gattaca in which you had you know people
who were who were enhanced and then you
had people who weren't enhanced and the
people who were in now said a special
place in society and guess what the
people who weren't enhanced rebelled are
we now creating super human beings are
we now creating killer viruses are we
now creating massive joblessness are we
now creating all of these new nightmares
with technologies do the rewards truly
outweigh the risks and then the question
is there's a technology great autonomy
of our dependence I mean I'm a big fan
of self-driving cars that I Drive a
Tesla Model S and I can't wait to get
into Auto Drive when I get on the
highway because I want the car to drive
itself now eventually when I say
eventually probably 10 15 years from now
we're gonna be deciding that we don't
want these dangerous human beings on the
road these human beings get distracted
they text while they're driving they get
angry they get road rage they rush into
traffic at the same time they crash into
each other they're dangerous we don't
want these dangerous animals on our
roads instead we want to have smart AI
and robots doing the driving so we may
throw the human beings off the road
which means that we've lost autonomy
right we get angry
gone are the tales of driving so on the
one hand self-driving cars
give us a tana me why autonomy because
everyone now can get from it any way
they want to be to be where they want to
be
safely mothers can send their children
to school knowing that they'll safely
arrive there the people they're blind
the people who are handicapped the old
don't have to worry about you know
having to drive anymore we have autonomy
like we've never had before because of
self-driving cars but then we lose
another autonomy that autonomy is the
right of being able to drive on our
highways so you have a trade-off over
here the question is does it lead to
does technology lead to dependence or
autonomy in the case of self-driving
cars it's both dependence and autonomy
at the same time but we got to figure
this out we've got to figure out what
the trade-offs are so what I posit in
driving the driverless car is that we
have to look at each technology
technology through this you know these
three lenses and what I believe what I
sincerely believe is that if we get
these right that if we now benefit
everyone and we do things in a sensible
way we can create the amazing future of
Star Trek that we really can get to this
world in which we're now sharing
prosperity with seeking enlightenment
and knowledge we're working to uplift
humanity and we can do this 300 years at
a schedule
[Music]
you